[Música]
buenas tardes pues estoy aquí hoy como
invitado por algo que iniciamos hace
aproximadamente cinco años y que es un
tanto extraordinario y es justo lo que
lo que me trae aquí hoy este antes de
continuar me siento con la necesidad de
expresar dos puntos el primero es anotar
que mucho de lo que hablo hoy este
representa el trabajo de otros que son
parte de esta iniciativa que comparto
con ellos y el segundo punto es que este
en general somos escépticos de las
palabras pues justamente nosotros nos
dedicamos a las acciones y las primeras
las palabras este en muchas ocasiones
resultan espejismos tras más trampas y
distractores que muchas veces
obstaculizan nuestra labor
sin embargo es cierto que en ocasiones
es necesario hablar para poder explicar
lo que uno hace y por qué lo hacen
y cierto también es que de todo se
origina con una idea
y a mí me cuesta trabajo ubicar el
inicio
pero me gusta pensar en el centro de
túnez en diciembre de 2010 y de 2010
cuando mohamed buazizi un joven de 26
años se levantó temprano como todos los
días con el fin de ir a surtir frutas y
verduras
para surtir su carreta ambulante en el
centro de la ciudad este su trabajo le
permitía mantener a sus fincas a sus
cinco hermanos pequeños y a su madre que
había quedado viuda desde que mohamed
tenía diez años
esa mañana del 10 de diciembre de 2010
mohamed e inició su día como cualquier
día de trabajo cuando un grupo de
policías se acercaron
y lo interpelaron pues no contaba con
una licencia para vender esto no era la
primera vez que sucedía le confiscan su
mercancía y su báscula
este
él va al edificio de gobierno del centro
de la ciudad
e intenta recuperar sus bienes es
humillado no se le permite ni la entrada
y entonces es desesperado enojado y
enojado se dirige a una estación de
gasolina cercana compra un poco de
combustible y regresa frente al edificio
de gobierno en medio de la calle grito
desesperado como quieren que vivamos
para después vertirse el líquido y
prenderse en llamas aún con vida mohamed
fue llevado al hospital donde donde
moriría semanas después
pero días después de la involución la
gente en túnez
iniciaría una serie de protestas que
terminarían por derrocar a su presidente
dictador que por casi 20 años había
regido a ese país autoritario el 14 de
enero diez días después de la muerte en
fuego este cuando mohamed fue cuando
murió las protestas que derrocaron a
éste al presidente huyó a arabia saudita
la noticia que recorrió el mundo
y multiplicaría las protestas en todo el
medio oriente en egipto las masas
inspiradas por lo que sucedió en todo en
túnez derrocarían a su propio dictador
hosni mubarak que con mano férrea había
gobernado egipto por 30 años en libia la
intervención mañosa de las fuerzas
occidentales acabaría con la vida del
también dictador mohamed k cada fin
las protestas se extenderían a yemen
bahrein jordania argelia y siria
pero fue en siria donde el conflicto la
muerte y la destrucción llegaría para
quedarse
eso fue en 2011 cuando la guerra en
siria e inició y desde hace 8 años ha
provocado la crisis humanitaria más
grave de nuestra historia
alrededor de 6 millones de personas se
han vuelto refugiadas hay más de 400.000
muertos y hay más de un millón de
personas heridas
en ese tiempo estaba yo en afganistán en
la ciudad de kabul
donde había llegado dos años antes
también para trabajar como parte de los
esfuerzos humanitarios de una
organización americana
fue entonces cuando la crisis en siria
inició que yo he decidido mudarme a
beirut para poder estar trabajando de
cerca con los primeros refugiados que
por mí les cruzaban la frontera
de siria el líbano
después de este tiempo yo estuve un año
en líbano y posteriormente la crisis
siria incrementaba su intensidad y los
refugiados comenzaron a irse también a
otros países que ya estaban en crisis
como es el caso de irak fue entonces
cuando en 2000 en 2013 me mudé a irak y
comienza a trabajar en campos de
refugiados sirios que habían llegado a
el kurdistán
estando trabajando en los campos de
refugiados
vi a esta humanidad de gente jóvenes
gente vieja que ahora vivía en casas de
campaña y ahí conocí a una serie de
jóvenes de nacionalidad siria con los
que convivía todos los días
y era gente que no tenía ninguna
perspectiva que lo único que hacía era
levantarse para ver terminar el día era
joven sana inteligente con energía pero
no tenían una oportunidad por el hecho
de ser refugiados
fue entonces cuando en 2014 renunció a
mi trabajo después de haber recorrido
pakistán afganistán líbano y siria y
regreso a méxico
con la firme intención de crear un
puente por medio del cual jóvenes sirios
que por la guerra no podían continuar
sus estudios pudiesen venir a nuestro
país
para poder adquirir las herramientas
necesarias para reconstruir su país una
vez llegada la paz
eso fue en 2000 finales del 2013 cuando
yo estaba en irak y pensé que sería algo
sencillo pensé que en un año yo podría
establecer este puente y regresar a
a mi trabajo han pasado cinco años y al
día de hoy han llegado 15 jóvenes sirios
solo 15 jóvenes sirios de diferentes
partes de dentro de siria y desplazados
en diferentes países de la región como
irak líbano turquía y la propia siria y
yemen
y
cuando nosotros iniciamos este proyecto
pensamos que sería fácil pues la gente
siempre nos nos daba la bienvenida sin
embargo hemos también sufrido de el
obstáculo que representan las palabras
dado que
una cosa es hacer y otra cosa es hablar
cuando cuando yo hice mi carrera
profesional yo vivía en ginebra suiza
trabajaba para naciones unidas
y todo consistía en hablar todo todo el
trabajo era hablar yo no me sentía
legitimado para hablar pues no tenía no
había hecho nada fue cuando decidí de
partir en pakistán e iniciar una carrera
que me diera la experiencia para poder
hablar
y cuando iniciamos el proyecto sabes que
es la iniciativa por la cual llegan
estos jóvenes hemos encontrado
justamente esta barrera las palabras
nosotros como sociedad civil hemos
tomado un tema que le corresponde al
estado que es el tema de los refugiados
y hemos decidido implementarlos con
nuestras propias manos y van cinco años
y hemos logrado la llegada de 15 jóvenes
que es poco sin embargo representa un
puente un puente un puente claro que hoy
que lo implementamos vamos descubriendo
nuevas virtudes y en 2015 fue la llegada
del primer joven sirio y salsa sand
proveniente de de hama el siguiente año
llegaron otros
cuatro jóvenes provenientes de
diferentes zonas de siria y el año
pasado recibimos a 8 personas entonces
ha sido un proceso paulatino en el cual
nosotros nos hemos tenido que enfrentar
a una serie de obstáculos y de críticas
de
de mucha gente que cree que esto el tema
de los refugiados no es prioritario sin
embargo nosotros creemos que
todos los problemas del mundo nos
competen y todos somos corresponsables
de abordarlos y enfrentarlos desde
nuestras propias
iniciativas entonces
cuando yo inicié esta plática comentaba
que somos escépticos de las palabras
porque precisamente
nosotros decidimos tomar el tema por
nuestras manos e implementarlo
y mirar sobre todo a las acciones
reales que puedan tener un efecto
real en la vida de las personas con las
que interactuamos entonces yo no sé
exactamente cuál es en muchas ocasiones
el sentido de reunirnos y compartir este
tipo de experiencias si acaso nos va a
llevar a hacer algo nosotros si el caso
nos va a inspirar
a realizar una acción en nuestra
comunidad o si acaso es sólo una
agradable tarde que bien podría ser
intercambiable por una ideal cine
lo que a mí me queda es compartir una
experiencia de un grupo de personas
y tomamos
algo que parecía imposible y lo
convertimos en realidad gracias a
acciones
de todos los días tenemos cinco años
trabajando en este en esta iniciativa y
no hay un día que nosotros descansemos
hasta lograr nuestra meta que nos
establecimos hace cinco años que era la
llegada de 30 jóvenes sirios
celebramos el quinceavo hace unos meses
y seguimos trabajando en eso entonces
pues mi invitación es a reflexionar
sobre causas que les sean queridas y
generar un compromiso real y que perdure
en el tiempo pues solo lo que perdura en
el tiempo es lo que vale la pena y eso
se trabaja todos los días con un
compromiso muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]